[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat de
chronique et de reportage sur Public
Sénat 90 minutes pour donner du sens à
l'actualité avec deux grands thèmes
comme tous les soirs et d'abord la loi
immigration qui tourne au bras de fer la
ligne rouge de la régularisation des
travailleurs sans papier dans les
métiers en tension posés par le chef des
sénateurs LR Bruno retaillot fait
craindre une situation de blocage de la
Haute Assemblée comment le président du
Sénat Gérard Larché uvre-t-il en
coulisse pour débloquer justement cette
situation pourquoi des parlementaires
qui vont du Parti communiste à l'aile
gauche de la macronie profite de cette
réforme pour afficher leur convergence
ce sera notre premier débat dans une
minute et puis dans 3ois quart d'heure
direction la Turquie de récep Tayip
erdoganam
TER le Hamas n'est pas un groupe de
terroristes c'est un groupe de
libérateur et de mid qui se battent pour
protéger leurs terres et leurs
citoyens pourquoi le président tur
a-t-il durci son discours antiisraël
a-t-il renoncé à jouer un rôle de
médiateur auquel son pays à la fois
membre de l'OTAN et historiquement
proche du Hamas pourrait postuler comme
chaque jour depuis un mois on tentera de
dévoiler le dessous Descartes de ce
conflit au Proche Orient grâce à nos
invités experts mais d'abord donc on
détaille comment la majorité sénatoriale
ici au Sénat fait évoluer le texte
immigration avec Mathias
Arz la bataille sur le texte immigration
est belle et bien lancée pendant près de
3H la discussion générale a posé les
enjeux d'un texte d'équilibre aillant
entre un volet répressif et un autre
plus social à en croire son premier
défenseur géralde Darmanin le texte que
propose le gouvernement ici devant vous
est ouvert à la discussion avec le
Parlement avec le Sénat pour construire
ensemble un texte ferme un texte juste
et surtout un texte efficace après avoir
chacun posé leurs lignes rouges les
groupes ont établi leur stratégie
vis-à-vis du texte la droite sénatoriale
décide de le durcir à l'image de
l'adoption d'un article prévoyant la
mise en place de quotas pour
l'immigration économique dans
l'hémicycle la mesure a fait bondir la
gauche nous ne pouvons pas aujourd'hui
laisser croire y compris à la population
de notre pays que la politique des quota
serait une réponse cela ne fonctionne
pas la première journée s'est achevée
par l'adoption de plusieurs articles qui
rendent plus difficile les conditions
d'accès au regroupement familial ce
mardi c'est par l'intégration au texte
de mesurees restrictive à l'accès au
titre de séjours étranger malad ou de
contrôle du caractère réel et sérieux
des études que les sénateurs de droite
ont poursuivi leur entreprise il n'y a
aucun droit acquis aux étrangers à
entrer sur le territoire français de
n'importe quelle façon et il me semble
qu'il nous appartient de fixer les
conditions auxquelles les étrangers
rentrent avant l'examen du très attendu
article 3 repoussé en fin de semaine les
parlementaires se pencheront sur
d'autres gros morceaux du texte comme la
transformation de l'aide médicale d'État
en une aide médicale d'urgence plus
limitée pourquoi la droite se divise sur
ce texte immigration c'est l'un des
grands thèmes de notre débat avec
laurenceer bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
directrice du centre de réflexion destin
commun Pascal pereno bonsoir bienvenue
politologue professeur à Sciences Po
Paris an Charline beina bonsoir et
bienvenue vous êtes constitutionnaliste
et maître de conférence en droit public
j'accueille également Laétitia crupa
bonsoir ltiti bienvenue à vous
éditorialiste politique question un peu
générale pour commencer ce Laurence de
nerveau je commence avec vous ce texte
immigration est-ce qu' fait office d'une
certaine façon de révélateur là en ce
moment pour la droite
sénatoriale alors effectivement je pense
que ce texte est déjà dans les tuyaux et
en débat depuis un certain temps et là
les divisions éclatent au grand jour à
la fois celle entre la droite et la
gauche mais aussi au sein de la droite
he c'est ce qu'on voit là en ce moment
même au moment où n parlant à quelques
encablures d'ici et je pense qu'il faut
reprendre ce texte dans son ensemble un
texte qui qui visait un équilibre qui
qui avait choisi certaines dispositions
certaines certaines lignes et
aujourd'hui on voit que certaines autres
viennent se rajouter ce se s'additionner
qui sont chacune étiqueté comme des
lignes rouge des marqueurs et cetera
chacun y va de son terme de plus en plus
fort la droite étant un petit peu dans
un un une sorte d'ultimatum aujourd'hui
pour pour essayer de de de tenir sa
place de tenir son rang oui et puis on
verra si cette histoire de ligne rouge
c'est pas aussi un piège politique
Pascal Pino euh c'est c'est le premier
grand texte législatif qui vient au
Sénat après le renouvellement après les
élections sénatoriales de septembre
c'est c'est pas c'est pas neutre
évidemment est-ce que c'est le moment où
finalement on se compte j'ai les
centristes au sein du du groupe LR bien
sûr d'ailleurs les équilibres au sein de
la majorité ont évolué depuis les
dernières sénatoriales le groupe LR
s'est un peu affaibli euh et chacun en
effet se compte se juge se jauge mais il
faut savoir qu'il y avait une il y a une
certaine ambigué dans ce fameux projet
de loi d'armanin parce que au départ par
exemple la question de l'article 3
n'était pas prévu c'était un texte qui
devait renforcer les conditions
d'accueil des des des des migrants et
puis peu à peu il y a eu comment dire
cette espèce de refoulé macronien qui a
fait retour c'est la volonté du en même
temps en même temps on est ferme mais
voilà on ouvre et l'article
3 va un peu dans dans dans ce sens et
pour bien sûr la droite sénatoriale
c'est un peu un chiffon rouge hein c'est
un chiffon rouge en effet là ils disent
euh c'est un texte qui doit rester sur
la rigueur sur la fermeté le débat
aujourd'hui l'a montré à la fois sur
l'évolution de l'aide médicale sur
l'introduction de de cotas et sur le
refus pour l'instant de toute forme
d'article 3 dans la rédaction tel
qu'elle estimportant dans vre pH c'est
pour l'instant voilà pour l'instant
parce qu'on va voir ce qu'il en est
après les négociations qui semblent être
vives au moment d'ailleurs où l'on parle
afin d'arriver à un compromis parce qu'
il y a un compromis également à dans la
majorité sénatoriale parce que c'est
vrai qu'entre le groupe LR et le groupe
d'union centriste dirigé par r Marseille
il y a des différences particulièrement
sur cet article 3 et puis il faut bien
savoir que dans le groupe de l'Union
centriste il y a à la fois des gens qui
sont dans l'opposition mais il y a des
gens qui sont dans la majorité et donc
cel c'est la subtilité du Sénat donc ça
complexifiernormément le travail avecina
pour pour le président du Sénat Gérard
larch il y a quand même un un enjeu un
objectif important rappeler la capacité
de la Haute Assemblée à trouver des
compromis sous-entendu regarder du côté
de l'Assemblée nationale qui n'y arrive
pas quoi alors on on va dire qu'en plus
sur notre 5e République l'idée que le
Sénat soit la première assemblée en
première ligne comme ça à être en
quelque sorte au rendez-vous de cette
majorité relative c'est assez inédit
donc oui à la question est-ce que c'est
un test pour la pour le groupe LR mais
c'est un test pour le Sénat aussi en
effet de se de se promouvoir en tant que
chambre du compromis parce que je l'ai
pas dit mais c'est c'est ce texte il
vient en premier au Sénat ce pas
forcément ce qui pas l'habitude ex en
première lecture ce qui ce qui est pas
très habituelle et en plus il faut
rajouter que c'est toute tout l'art du
Sénat de savoir travailler entre groupes
qui ont eux-mêmes des colorations très
différentes de celles de l'Assemblée
nationale donc au fond on se rend compte
qu'ici on va être amené à à travailler
entre centristes de différents bords
entre LR de différents bords et donc on
doit arriver à trouver qu'est-ce que
c'est que ce qu'on narrive pas à faire à
l'Assemblée nationale avec la majorité
relative et c'est pas à noodin que le
gouvernement cherche ça parce que c'est
une manière de se dire est-ce qu'on va
pouvoir gouverner avec ce Parlement
pendant encore 4 ans donc c'est un
nouveau test on change les choses par
rapport à la réforme des retrait on
change d'assemblée et on va voir si le
deal marche cette fois-ci alors vous
vous parliez de l'aide médicale d'État
pasal pin on va on va détailler un peu
les arguments autour de de ce thème mais
d'abord je vous propose deux témoignages
parce que pour peser finalement sur ces
débats au Sénat il y a plusieurs
associations des des syndicats des
associations de défense des sanspiers
qui manifestent depuis hier je propose
deux témoignages deux participants qui
rappelle qu'ils participent eux aussi à
la croissance économique du pays ceux
qui sont là ils sont là ils sont en
France ils travaillent ils participent à
la richesse de la France ils participent
au développement de la France et donc
ils cotisent ils n'ont pas de sécurité
sociale donc comment un pays comme la
France qui se dit qui respecte les
droits de l'homme les gens sont là et on
les respecte même pas et c'est comme du
mépris on les ignore nous sommes là pour
dire aux sénateurs aux sénatrices que ce
projet de loi là ne va rien faire que de
nous criminaliser immigré est égal à
déinc en gros et encore plus loin il
prévoit de supprimer a aide médicale de
l'état en disant c'est ça coûte cher
c'est
faux notre santé c'est la santé des
Français aussi des Françaises un immigré
qui est malade la maladie peut se
propager partout la maladie ne regarde
ni tit de séjour cou l'aide médicale
d'État que la majorité sénatoriale veut
limiter à une aide médicale d'urgence
laence de nerveau est-ce qu'elle est une
source d'abus au point de devoir la
réformer cette aide médicale d'État si
cher que çaors commençons d'abord par
rappeler que ce point n'était pas dans
le texte initial évidemment il fait
partie des gages que la majorité
envisage de donner à la droite gag de
fermeté voilà bon euh sur la question du
du rapport à la santé quand on parle
immigration on parle d'un certain nombre
peut-être de droits qui vont être
octroyés à ces personnes étrangères qui
arrivent en France nous avons interrogé
les Français récemment sur la question
de savoir finalement quels sont les
droits qui vous semblent devoir être de
façon prioritaire préservés pour ces
personnes étrangères et bien le droit à
la santé arrive en premier c'est celui
que les Français souhaitent le plus
protéger celui auquel ils sont le plus
attachés plus largement ils y sont
attachés au titre d'un modèle social
français humaniste qui est cons tif de
leur vision de notre pays voilà alors
est-ce que ça coûte cher tout est
relatif aujourd'hui le chiffre qu'on a
c'est 1 milliard 2 je pense que c'est
essentiel de toujours mettre en
perspective les ordres de grandeur un
chiffre dans l'absolu n'a pas beaucoup
de sens quand on pense aux dépenses de
santé de l'État français dans leur
ensemble alors on peut donner une
fourchette selon qu'on y inclut
l'ensemble des frais de de prévention et
du fonctionnement de notre système de
santé ça peut monter jusqu'à 300 et
quelques milliards d'euros ou de 220 si
on prend un un une 1 milliard 2 versus
on va prendre de la fourchette 200
milliards effectivement relativise il
faut toujours mettre ses chiffrre en
perspective après évidemment il y a des
évolutions donc c'est c'est sain je
pense de faire des contrôles mais ce qui
est certain c'est que l'idée selon
laquelle l'ame serait largement
responsable de de des difficultés de
notre système de santé aujourd'hui ne
tient pas du tout debout vous dites ça
ne tient pas debout Pascal Perino c'est
c'est pas un qu'elle soit cette aide
médicale d'État dans le collimateur de
la droite puis on pourrait rajouter de
l'extrême droite ça fait longtemps hein
qu'elle est qu'elle est dans le
collimateur mais est-ce que c'est un
cliché euh c'est pas tout à fait un
cliché parce qu'il y a le niveau en
effet un milliard d' enfin à l'heure où
on commence à vouloir se poser la
question de la restriction des dépenses
publiques faut bien commencer par un
bout bon voilà euh mais mais surtout
quand vous regardez ça dans la dynamique
la hausse de l'aide médicale d'État est
extrêmement importante c'est plus 40 %
en 10 ans h hein donc certains disent
voilà il y a une forme de croissance
exponentielle et il faut donner un coup
d'arrêt alors le débat est ouvert il ne
s'agit pas de supprimer l'aide médicale
aux irréguliers il s'agit de substituer
de la restreinte de restreindre comme on
dit le panier de soins de soins
remboursé mais l'argument de d'un des
manifestants bah il sera moins bien
soigner donc
potentiellement ça peut une maladie
effectivement ça peut se transmettre à
d'utr la prophylaxie ça existe
tout à fait donc il peut y avoir en
effet des euh des des des eff mais c'est
intéressant parce que l'argument de
santé publique on peut le retourner
c'est ça mais derrière il y a au fond
quoi il y a la question sur lequelle il
y a un débat qui n'est pas facile c'est
le coût de l'immigration hein est-ce que
l'immigration rapporte plus qu'elle ne
coûte ou non et là le débat n'est pas un
débat facile et la réponse n'est pas
simplement oui ou non voyez oui oui
effectivement et et c'est là que ça
devient vraiment intéressante char parce
que là on pourrait finalement avoir un
débat avec des chiffres enfin presque le
plus neutre possible sauf que sur cette
thématique de l'imigration quand on
entend nos nos responsables politiques
on n'est pas du tout dans ce registre là
on est d'abord dans des postures dans
d'idéologie est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça c'est dans l'ADN des
lois immigration de de toute façon
cristalliser les positions de chacun
d'amener aussi à une forme de débat
entre l'humanisme la fermeté je pense
que en 40 ans pour ça par interrompe
cette loi pour cliver d'une certaine
façon pour pour que chacun choisisse son
camp on a plusieurs fois parlé du terme
de marqueur mais nécessairement cette
loi immigration sera là en effet pour
que chacun retrouve ses marqueurs après
la réforme des retraites qui a qui a pas
forcément permis d'avoir des des des des
des des couloir idéologique très
important j'ajoute que sur l'ame il y a
peut-être encore un autre chiffon rouge
derrière que celui du coup de
l'immigration qui est celui au fond de
ce fameux appel d'air dont parle Bruno
retaillot parce que c'est vrai que on a
souvent eu et je pense notamment au
débat pendant la campagne présidentielle
où laame faisait plus ou moins toujours
partie des questions qui étaient posées
aux différents participants et où on se
rendait compte que il y avait un faux
ami derrière en ayant cette impression
que le le caractère solidaire et
finalement profondément social de la
France c'est dans le préembule de notre
Constitution hein donne le sentiment que
cette france terre d'accueil terre
d'asile notamment à travers cette ame
peut amener à ce que les immigrés
choisissent cette terre plus qu'une
autre et donc je crois qu'au fond c'est
pas àodin que cet élément-là soit devenu
un gage
h ré par c'est manère de
leameuxessage de fermeté mais
précisément sur ce point si vous me
permettez ellisabeth born qui elle-même
s'est exprimé contre la supression de
laame ou du moins sa transformation en
Amu a commandité un rapport he pour
évaluer ces ces différents éléments
voilà il semble que sur les premières
conclusions qui étaient rendu disponies
ce ne soit pas du tout aussi net que ça
cette question d'un éventuel appel d'air
d'ailleurs ça rejoint la question des
métiers en tenstion là aussi l'un des
principaux arguments donné pour euh pour
ne ne ne pas voter cet article 3 c'est
la théorie de l'appel destiens on va en
parler tout de suite de cet article 3
grâce à Quentin calm qui doit être juste
derrière le rideau de sens public
bonsoir Quentin bienvenue à
vous on vit une époque de feuilleton en
quelque sorte sur sur Public Sénat et il
y a celui de l'article 3 de ce projet de
loi immigration alors le dernier épisode
c'est le report de l'examen de cette
mesure dites-nous tout voilà on aurait
dû examiner l'article 3 dans les
prochaines mais la rumeur circulait
depuis hier elle a été officialisée ce
matin il est urgent d'attendre les
sénateurs temporisent se donne du temps
sur cette mesure controversée à droite
écoutez au micro de jeathend du Priz le
président de la commission des Lois du
Sénat le LR François Noë buffet j'ai été
autorisé par la commission des lois ce
matin à demander à la reprise de la sé
de la séance la réserve sur le chapitre
2 de façon à qu'il soit reporté alors un
peu plus loin dans le texte
ça ne parlera à personne mais après
l'article 13 et de ce fait que nous
puissions avoir un temps suffisant pour
continuer de travailler voilà c'est tout
ce que je peux vous dire à ce stade
voilà tout le chapitre 2 ce sont tous
les articles qui concernent
l'intégration par le travail dont
l'article 3 car le texte a beau avoir
été présenté par les ministres il y a 1
an que il a été examiné en commission en
mars dernier et bien l'article 3 il
cristallise toujours autant les tensions
politiques et donc on va rappeler ce que
contient cet article 3 dans le projet du
gouvernement voilà ce volet du texte
crée un titre de séjour pour un étranger
en situation régulière qui Résid en
France depuis plus de 3 ans qui
travaille dans un métier ou une zone
géographique en tension où il y a des
difficultés de recrutement pendant au
moins 8 mois lors des deux années
précédentes et le travailleur n'aura
plus besoin de son employeur pour faire
la demande de régularisation et puis on
a commencé par ça on parlait de bras de
fer c'est vraiment l'objet du bras de
fer entre la droite et le centre ici au
Sénat exactement les alr ne veulent pas
du tout de de cette partie du texte les
centristes eux y tiennent et s'opposent
à leurs alliés de la majorité du Sénat
on rappelle d'ailleurs la composition
politique du Sénat on va comprendre la
droite seule leslr en bleu foncé et bien
elle n'a pas la majorité absolue ici à
la Chambre haute vous le voyez et
puisque la majorité absolue elle est à
180 sièges donc et bien elle pourrait se
retrouver la droite en minorité si elle
veut supprimer seule l'article 3 du
projet de loi et on comprend mieux cette
rallonge de temps pour négocier
évidemment avant que ce soit examiné en
séance voilà mais depuis ce matin les
chefs de fil à droite sur le projet de
loi immigration il n'en démorde pas
l'article 3 ce sera toujours non
négociation ou pas avec les centristes
il n'y aura pas l'article 3 on le
comprend avec les négociations écoutez à
notre micro la rapporteur LR du texte
Muriel Jourda sa position rappelle celle
de leur chef de fil Bruno retaillot
écoutez on ne peut pas voter un texte
qui ne correspond pas à ce qu'on
souhaite réellement
et le texte tel qu'il existe aujourd'hui
souffle à la fois le chaud et le froid
si on si nous votons un texte qui à la
fois durcit une politique d'immigration
mais est plus laxiste sur des conditions
d'intégration qui sont en fait des
conditions des
régularisation beaucoup trop importantes
et bien il s'avère que nous aurons un
texte qui ne sert à rien donc nous ne
voterons pas un texte qui ne sert à rien
donc les LR et les centristes se donnent
plusieurs jours pour négocier c'est ce
qu'ils sont en train de faire à l'heure
où l'on se parle et la théorie qui tient
laaccorde c'est qu'il serait en en train
de se mettre d'accord sur le
durcissement de la circulaire Vals
circulaire un règlement de 2012 qui
permet de délivrer des titres de séjour
pour les salariés mais donc les alr
continuent de faire de l'article 3 une
ligne rouge d'ailleurs pour finir sur
cet article 3 quid d'un texte qui
contiendrait un article 3 les alr
pourrait alors refuser de voter sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi oui et c'est
là qu'on pourrait parler d'une crise
assez grave puisque le le le texte
pourrait ne ne pas être adopté ici au
Sénat voilà c'est en ça que l'article 3
est donc devenu un totem politique he
c'est l'expression qui revient pour tous
les groupes politique et c'est l'avenir
de l'ensemble du projet de loi qui est
en jeu à suivre donc maintenant
probablement mercredi fin d'après-midi
ou dans la soirée ce sera à suivre en
direct et en intégralité sur notre
antenne évidemment on diffusera en
direct les les les débats au sein de de
l'hémicycle Pascal Perino je revient
verdou pour peut-être pour détailler le
rôle de Gérard Larcher en ce moment
est-ce qu'il est en train d'essayer de
convaincre Bruno otillot de mettre des
pointiller à sa ligne rouge oui
certainement ça doit aller dans ce
sens-là pourquoi parce que on le disait
tout à l'heure le président du Sénat
voit le Sénat honoré par le fait que on
discute ce qui est en effet un cas rare
on discute en première lecture euh au au
Sénat parce qu'on se dit au fond on peut
pas travailler à l'Assemblée nationale
on peut pas travailler à l'Assemblée pas
texte on pourrait dire la même chose on
peut pas travailler au exactement donc
c'est une question d'image du Sénat qui
est en cause euh on s'est tourné on
s'est tourné le gouvernement sour vers
le Sénat en se disant voilà c'est tout
de même une culture du compromis et
c'est une réalité au Sénat une culture
de compromis extrêmement ancienne c'est
dans les murss sénatoriales ça s'incarne
particulièrement bien dans son président
Gérard Larcher donc quelque part Gérard
Larcher en ce moment oui est responsable
de l'image du Sénat est-ce que le Sénat
est à l'image de l'Assemblée nationale
c'est une assemblée impossible on ne
peut pas vraiment travailler où on va de
dramatisation en dramatisation un espèce
d'une sorte de théâtre d'ombre oou
est-ce que le Sénat est véritablement
une chambre qui fait les preuve que le
travail parlementaire ça a du sens le
compromis parlementaire ça a du sens et
c'est ça ce qui est en train de se jouer
en ce moment et sur le fond du texte sur
cette idée d'appel d'air est-ce que
voilà le fait de voter cet article 3 ça
voilà ça ça provoquera un appel si on
regarde ce qui existe on parlait de la
circulaire Vals est-ce que ça a provoqué
un appel d'air alors techniquement on
peut pas dire que cet article 3 va
vraiment révolutionner euh euh la
surface du du monde migratoire parce que
euh c'est vrai que aujourd'hui déjà
c'est on entend souvent que c'est
aujourd'hui un changement avec
surdemande du salarié ou sur demande de
l'employeur il faut rappeler que c'est
un SERFA de l'employeur mais toujours
sur demande du salarié hein donc ça ça
change pas du tout le demandeur
néanmoins c'est vrai que euh il y a
cette idée euh qui est pas très claire
dans le dans la majorité de savoir si ça
va être de plein droit c'estàd
h ou aura des
conditionqu je CIS cet article 3 mérite
d'être discuté d'être encore précisé
dans contour parce que on n'est pas
forcément sûr de savoir ce qu'il va
changer au droit évidemment ça peut
passer par la loi comme ça peut passer
par un acte administratif on le dit
aujourd'hui c'est le préfet qui dirige
absolument tout en matière de
régularisation et titre de séjour et ça
n'est pas quelque chose qui est amené à
changer tout simplement parce que le
préfet le représentant de l'État dans
les territoires donc ça sera toujours
l'autorité pivot néanmoins cet article 3
c'est un un peu l'article 7 de la
réforme des retraites c'est-à-dire que
c'est celui autour duquel tout tourne en
terme de totem politique et je crois que
le rôle de Gérard Larcher est marquant
notamment par rapport au fait que il
faut essayer de faire que cet article 3
ne soit pas justement ce totem et qu'on
arrive à pouvoir le lisser parce que
ajoutons que l'article 3 est clivant
mais que dire alors de l'article 4 qui
lui-même continue cette lignée de la
régularisation des métiers en tension
avec l'examen de français qui font
partie de ce chapitre 2 donc en fait on
pourrait vraiment élargir à beau tic
c'est un ou c'est un prétexte pour
s'opposer alors je suis pas sûr
d'ailleurs que tous les membres du
groupe LR soient sur la même ligne à ce
propos on a Bruno rotaillot qui en effet
a pris la le lead sur cette question
d'en faire quelque chose de clivant mais
au fond je pense que c'est possible de
trouver un compromis sans perdre
complètement la face parce que c'est ça
qui se joue aussi c'est l'unité du
groupe LR au Sénat à la suite vous
l'avez dit de la de l'élection
sénatoriale donc faut montrer de l'unité
et j'ajoute que c'est intéressant euh de
voir que les compromis se font
finalement hors de l'Assemblée puisqu'on
voit bien que c'est au sein du groupe LR
avec les sous les git de de Gérard
Larché que indépendamment de l'hémicycle
on essaie de discuter donc c'est
intéressant il y a quand même moi je je
le redis euh c'est ma conviction
profonde une forme d'hypocrisie face à
ce que euh ces travailleurs immigrés
apportent à l'économie française quoi
c'està-dire que tous les uns et les
autres on va dans des restaurants on
commande sur internet euh on fait
construire des maisons euh tiens les
Jeux Olympiques il y a beaucoup de de
sans papier qui sont sur les chantiers
bref je pourrais rallonger la liste
Laurence de nerveau est-ce que ça vous
énerve ça cette espèce d'hypocrisie
générale je suis pas sûr que ce soit le
sujet de ce qui m'énerve personnellement
mais en tout cas je peux vous donner des
éclairages sur ce qu'en pensent les
Français quand on parle immigration on
parle aussi intégration quand il s'agit
d'intégration les Français sont très au
clair sur le fait que le travail est une
condition première de l'intégration une
condition quasiment synequanon ce sont
Français sur 10 qui considèrent que les
personnes migrantes doivent travailler
pour mieux s'intégrer à la société
française 89 % oui mais mais il demande
aussi plus de fermeté et d'ordre donc a
un petit peu de contradiction oui tout à
fait mais quand même pour préciser les
choses sur cette question du travail on
est aussi dans un contexte en ce moment
proche du plein emploi même s'il y a
encore un petit peu de chômage en France
bien sûr qui fait que le la sensation de
concurrence vis-à-vis du travail est
bien moindre que dans une période
antérieure de ce point de vue làà ce
sont trois Français sur quatre qui
considèrent que les personnes migrantes
aujourd'hui euh en fait remplissent des
emplois que les Français ne veulent pas
donc en fait le le le travail des
personnes issus de l'immigration est
perçu aujourd'hui plutôt comme une
opportunité voire comme une nécessité du
point de vue économique alors je vous
interrompe parce que je vais vous
laisser conclure votre démonstration
mais je vous propose parce que on a
vraiment un j'entends ce que vous dites
et je me dis tiens j'ai une réaction
d'éc soti qui dit quasiment l'inverse
justement sur le nombre de Français sans
emploi le nombre de travailleurs
immigrés qui qui occupent des postes
écout
éti on a 5 millions de Français inscrits
à Pô emploi et on a 400000 étrangers qui
sont en situation régulière eux qui sont
inscrits en P emploi et on aurait besoin
d'aller chercher des personnes qui se
trouvent en situation
irrégulière pas réaliste vous reprochez
au gouvernement d'être dans le flou je
vis que vous soyez très clair vous tant
qu'il y aura l'article 3 ou une mesure
qui ressemble article 3 même si c'est
hors de la loi ça sera non pour le
projet de loi immigration absolument
c'est très clair je l'ai dit depuis le
début on ne tergiverse pas nous nous
opposons à ce en même temps politicien
qui n'aura que des conséquences
négatives est-ce que les les je vous
laisse terminer est-ce que les
sympathisants LR sont sur la même ligne
que l'ensemble des Français par rapport
à cette question de travail et et
intégration je je vous ai dit que
c'était trois Français sur quatre qui
pensaient que les personnes migrantes
occupent des emplois que ne veulent pas
les français donc il reste un Français
sur quatre qui n'est pas d'accord avec
ça donc c'est sans doute effectivement
le cas de beaucoup de sympathisants LR
mais là où quand même je voudrais réagir
à ces ces mots d'éicoti de quels emplois
parle-t-on de quel français parle-t-on
là dans les emplois des des secteurs dit
en tenstion voilà lesquels de ces
emplois sont vraiment désirés convoités
par les Français qui sonent à P emploi
aujourd'hui voilà c'est cette question à
laquelle il faut faire face or nous ce
qu'on a entendu c'est une grande
lucidité de la part des Français qui
décrivent des cas concrets qu'il voit au
quotidien dans le secteur du BTP par
exemple dans le secteur de la
restauration vous l'avez dit Thomas
également dans le secteur des livraisons
avec une forme de malaise voire parfois
de honte aussi sur les conditions de
travail dans ces secteurs ou on voit
qu'il y a une popérisation encore accrue
des des
livreurs chiffres qui qu' disent a oui
tout à fait et et avec aussi la
conscience que souvent il y a des
phénomènes d'exploitation là c'est 7
Français sur 10 qui disent que un
certain nombre de personnes migrantes
sont exploité par leur employeurs avec
bah des exemples très concrets cette
personne qui dit dans le BTP je le voit
on les prend et on les jette donc si on
vous comprend bien et si on résume TR
français sur qu sont pour cet article 3
alors on l'a pas testé exactement comme
ça mais en tout cas il y a il y a
beaucoup de de de signes qui vont dans
ce sensl oui Pascal Perino non les
Français sont plus dans un rapport plus
modéré en ce qui concerne l'article 3
mais là faut faire très attention ce
sont des enquêtes dans lequel en deux
lignes on présente le contenu de
l'article 3 et on demande aux Français
de se prononcer donc faut être
extrêmement prudent mais je crois que le
problème si vous voulez là on parle
beaucoup de l'Immigration et de son
impact sur l'économique oui mais l'écho
euh dès qu'on parle d'immigration qu'il
y a un projet de loi sur l'immigration
c'est que maintenant l'immigration
touche à bien est une chambre d'éco de
bien d'autres problèmes le terrorisme
l'insécurité l'identité culturelle et
cetera et ce sont tous ces problèmes qui
sont convoqués par les Français et par
la classe politique qui à cet égard
n'est que le reflet de l'opinion et et
qui rendent toute gestion de la question
de l'immigration sur le plan politique
extrêmement difficile et extrêmement
passionnelle on voit très bien qu'il y a
des affects qui s'expriment chez les
hommes politiques et pas simplement des
analyses qui relève de l'analyse
rationnelle j'entends vos arguments mais
si on reprend la la formule caricaturale
binaire de Géral daranin méchant avec
les méchant gentil avec les gentils
c'est ce qui définissait d'une certaine
façon l'équili de ce texte on est de
moins en moins gentil avec les gentils
là ah ben si on est méchant avec les
méchants ça va d'accord ok on est dans
ce dans dans ce nouvel équilibre je
voudrais qu'on qu'on termine sur cette
histoire de ligne rouge an Charline
besina parce que il y a pas que Bruno
rotao qui tient le le pinceau Eric
sootti qu'on vient d'entendre lui lui
aussi est-ce que c'est pas quand même
aussi un piège politique c'estàdire que
Al pas seulement sur ce débat
immigration c'est quand on trace une
ligne rouge forcément on se on se
contraint et et on bloque toute capacité
de négociation parce que sinon on est au
confronté au risque de de se désavouer
pour piè poli c'est un bien sûr pour
beaucoup de raisons la première parce
que on peut encourir ce risque du fameux
493 faut pas l'oublier il n'est pas
possible au Sénat c'est important de le
dire mais il est possible à l'Assemblée
nationale donc quand le dégainé va-t-il
être dégainé oui ou non aura-t-il la
même côte d'impopularité qu'il a eu pour
la réforme des retrait alors queon l'a
dit les Français sont plutôt moins
défavorables à l'article 3 qu'à l'ex
article 7 de la réforme des retraites et
puis non seulement on encourt le risque
donc d'amener le gouvernement à à
prouver que vous n'êtes pas capable de
faire alliance et donc d'aller à ce
parlementarisme très dur et puis vous en
courz aussi le risque de diviser dans
votre propre famille parce que plus les
propos sont marqués on l'a dit pour
Bruno retaillot et pour Eric cotti plus
finalement des plus modéré pourrait
aller chercher des accords alternatifs
et vous pouvez tout à fait dissoudre
votre groupe donc il y a au moins ces
deux risques j'en voie aussi peut-être
un un troisième qui est celui de la
légitimité par rapport au Ren
c'est-à-dire que le rassemblement
national lui a l'air si on en croit sa
présidente de nous dire que ce petit
texte sur l'immigration pourrait quand
même être voté par le rassemblement
national mais pas par les républicains
qui apparaîtrait donc plus à droite que
le groupe que l'on qualifie d'extrême
droite donc on on en arrive à quelque
chose qui marche un petit peu sur la
tête et et je pense que c'est
précisément ce que Gérard Larché qu'on
loue souvent pour son pragmatisme
politique au moins en tout cas dans les
dans les qu'il recherche essaye d'éviter
c'est qu'on en arrive à ce que cette
ligne rouge soit aussi la balle dans le
pied du groupe des Républicains donc je
je crois que c'est vraiment ce qu'il
faut éviter ouais allez on va se poser
une question importante dans ce débat où
est passé Olivier du S laéticia je me
tourne vers vers vous puisque la la
communication et l'incarnation autour de
cette loi immigration elle a quand même
nettement changé le ministre du Travail
a quasiment disparu au profit du
ministre de l'Intérieur oui parce qu'au
début vous avez raison Thomas ils
étaient deux il y avait Gérald armanin
et Olivier du sopte finalement
l'ouverture la fermeture on l'a dit la
gauche la droite enfin on comprend ce
tandem qui avait été formé par
l'exécutif et ça avait commencé
d'ailleurs avec une interview au Monde
il y a 1 an le 2 novembre ça fait ça
fait quand même un moment que le
l'exécutif a lancé ce projet de loi
immigration et alors c'est intéressant
cette interview je l'ai retrouvé et le
journal avait retenu une phrase il y a
un an nous proposons de créer un titre
de séjour métier en tension donc vous
comprenez bien qu'Olivier du sopt était
sur le devant de la scène hein c'était à
lui d'aller porter cette loi avec cet
article 3 et il a honoré sa mission
jusqu'à il y a environ deux ou tris
semaines parce que j'ai remonté sa piste
oui alors vous avez relu ou revu ses
interviews c'est ça j'ai revu toutes ces
interviews et alors j'ai surtout remonté
son fil Twitter parce que c'est un
ministre qui tweet beaucoup quasiment
tous les jours et donc la dernière fois
où il salue son ami Gérald armanin
c'était le 6 octobre à l'occasion du
campus Renaissance et puis la dernière
fois où il parle du projet de loi
immigration c'est en repostant deux de
ces interviews l'une sur France Info qui
datait du 17 octobre et l'autre sur dans
le journal Le télégram du 21 octobre euh
c'était finalement toujours le même
message qu'Olivier du sopt délivrit on
en a parlé sur ce plateau il disait que
non non non les titres de séjour accordé
aux travailleurs sans papier mais avec
un contrat de travail légal ne feront
pas d'appel d'air c'est exactement ce
qu' disait ici même sur Public Sénat le
9 9 octobre 9 octobre dernier oui
pourquoi est-ce qu'il a disparu le
ministre du Travail justement au moment
où cette loi immigration arrive ici au
Sénat alors évidemment quand on pose la
question à matigon on nous dit ah non
pas du tout rien n'a changé alors quand
on gratte un petit peu hein et que on se
fait insistant on comprend deux choses
on comprend que finalement pour
l'exécutif Oliv du sopt a accompli sa
mission sa mission elle était simple
Thomas c'était la jambe gauche c'était
l'élément gauche Olivier du ST de la
macronie donc il devait ramener le
maximum de ses congénèes de gauche
macronienne avec lui et puis aussi
convaincre une partie de la majorité et
quand on a vu que la droite
s'engouffrait dans l'opposition avec une
telle vivacité on s'est dit alors ça
c'est du offre complet qu'Olivier du SOP
n'était peut-être pas outillé pour
répondre donc on l'a légèrement
débranché ça c'est le premier argument
et ensuite d'autant et c'est le deuxième
point que l'actualité avec le meurtre
Dominque Bernard à haras et le conflit
au Proche Orient rendait moins audible
cet article 3 et la rendait aussi moins
acceptable vous venez n de nous le dire
avec l'opinion publique française donc
on s'est dit que fallait mettre en avant
Gérald haranin voilà que Gérald armanin
qui depuis le début ça aussi on retrouve
l'article du Monde et l'interview du
mond an il le dit depuis le début il n'a
jamais bougé d'un yota il dit c'est le
texte de loi sur l'immigration le plus
ferme présenté par un gouvernement et on
s'est dit dans l'exécutif que c'était
effectivement ce message qu'on allait
privilégier et donc Gérald daranin
d'autant que pour le moment du sopt lui
sur l'article 3 laisse faire les
pourparler négociation mais il n'est pas
totalement débranché au lieu du sopt
pour l'instant il est en pause on va
dire qu'il est sur pause ok bien compris
derrière l'incarnation laurencear il y a
aussi l'équilibre de de de ce texte mais
surtout l'équilibre de la majorité
présidentielle euh je parle pas de la
majorité sénatorielle ici je parle de la
majorité présidentielle est-ce que ce
texte peut faire naître quoi on souvient
des fondeurs de François Hollande une
mécanique un peu similaire d'après vous
alors je trouve qu'on le voit en
particulier en en suivant les attitudes
et les prises de parole d'Élisabeth
borne h qui est dans une sorte
d'exercice d'équilibriste permanentin on
l'a entendu hier ou avant-hier sur
France interre euh on a dû reposer la
question de son son jugement sur la me à
trois reprises pour qu'elle finisse par
affirmer nettement sa sa position
différente de celle de géralde hermanin
et elle est toujours voilà dans cette
cette tentative de ménager l'alchèbre et
le chou elle sait que chaque voix compte
et que il va falloir trouver une voie de
passage pour éviter à tout prix un
nouveau 493 même si on sait qu'il
n'exclut pas cette cette option Infiné
je vous pose la question des nouveaux
fondeurs parce qu'on a on a vu nître une
sorte de de regroupement idéologique on
pourrait appeler ça comme ça du Parti
communiste jusqu'à l'aile gauche de la
macronie avec on va on va voir la la Une
de Libération qui date d'il y a 2 mois
on voit des personnalités qui vont de
Fabien Roussel à Sacha oulier qui signe
une tribune commune Pascal Perino est-ce
que c'est la
recomposition moi je envoy un photo je
me suis la recomposition post Emmanuel
Macron qui commence là sûr bien sûr si
vous voulez la macronide a a deux
faiblesses euh la première faiblesse
c'est son côté incroyablement composite
politiquement le E e ça va à condition
que j'allais dire les deux se mêlent la
droite et la gauche le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est que ça c'est pas mé
mêlé pardon il y a eu une phase de
gauche et puis maintenant il y a une
phase de droite euh très claire euh
deuxème faiblesse c'est que voilà la
Constitution prévoit que le le candidat
Macron ne pourra pas se représenter du
moins euh la PR donc le monde prépare la
suite tout le monde prépare la suite et
d'autre part la gauche est très
déstabilisée avec ce qui se passe au
sein de laanupes donc il y a en effet un
espace politique pour une recomposition
des forces de gauche
épars dispersé façon puzzle comme dirait
Michel odudiar oui autour de qui ça
c'est peut-être un peu trop tôt pour
répondre à la question et évidemment
mais c'est une question qui est très
importante qui va se reposer un certain
nombre de foisine Bina on évoque le 493
on rappelle que c'est pas ici au Sénat
mais c'est à à l'Assemblée nationale il
y a la question de la responsabilité
d'un éventuel 493 qui qui pourrait
porter enfin cette responsabilité
pourrait porter justement sur cette aile
gauche de la de la macronie donc je
repose la question des nouveaux fondeurs
est-ce que est-ce que ça peut être le
dessin de ce texte d'avoir d'abord euh
semé une forme de zizanie au sein de la
majorité de droite ici au Sénat pour
ensuite se met la zisani au sein de la
majorité présidentielle à l'Assemblée
alors il faut savoir que c'est en
réalité la vocation du 493 c'est-à-dire
que c'est ce qu'on appelle un outil du
parlementarisme rationalisé en gros de
la manière dont le gouvernement peut
reprendre les reennes et il reprend les
reine de quoi de sa majorité donc
précisément le 493 c'est l'outil
antifrondeur c'est-à-dire que c'est
grâce à ça que vous arrivez à
discipliner généralement comme le Michel
Rocard avec sa majorité relative au
seuil du vote au dernier moment pour
sécuriser un vote donc c'est tout à fait
possible que ce 493 serve ici à à
rassembler comme une forme d'épouvantail
c'est-à-dire que ok on n pas capable de
se mettre d'accord mais au moins on est
capable de ne pas être en disension
absolue au point de se démettre il y a
autre chose qui se joue c'est que en
effet le texte on le voit aujourd'hui
avec son article
3 avec une figure en quelque sorte qui
nous est présentée par le gouvernement
mais je pense que c'est important de
redire à quel point au cours d'une
discussion législative les articles même
changent l'article 3 deviendra sûrement
l'article 26 et les sénateurs ont déjà
profondément amendé le texte l'Assemblée
nationale risque de faire de même donc
on risque non seulement d'avoir un
puzzle mais d'avoir un patchwork
c'est-à-dire que à la fin des premières
lectures au sein des deux assemblées si
on retourne à une deè lecture au sein
des deux assemblées à quoi ressemblera
le texte au début du mois de décembre
c'est vraiment ça qu'à mon avis le
gouvernement doit craindre c'est une
forme de déconstruction avec l'idée que
chacun y met un petit peu du sien donc
le 493 peut aussi jouer le rôle de
reconstructeur d'un texte un petit peu
plus cohérent que celui qui sortira des
différents arbitres alors ce texte il
est vraiment passionnant parce qu' il
permet comme ça c'est c'estes
recomposition politiqu c'est ce qu'on
analyse depuis le début de ce ce débat
c'est également vrai quand on entend
Marion maréchal la la candidate du parti
reconquête du parti d'Éric Zemour pour
les élections européennes elle a lancé
l'idée d'un référendum d'initiative
partagé sur l'immigration elle
l'expliquait ce matin sur Europe 1 de
quoi parlons-nous aujourd'hui nous avons
65 % des Français qui veulent un
référendum sur l'immigration et entre 60
et 80 % selon les sondages d'opinion qui
veulent réduire l'immigration et malgré
ça le peuple français disons-le n'est
pas en entendu n'est pas écouté le
président ne veut pas s'engager à faire
un référendum sur le sujet il même si
pardonnez-moi hier il a envoyé une
lettre en indiquant sa volonté d'ouvrir
le champ du référendum qui son sociét il
tourne au tour sans jamais expliciter
clairement en effet que il souhait ce
référendum il ne s'y est pas engagé
malgré les demandes de certains partis
aujourd'hui l'ensemble des état-majors à
droite appelle ce référendum depuis
longtemps donc moi j'en ai tiré la
conclusion que plutôt que d'attendre la
bonne volonté d'un président qui se
refuse à écouter les Français
donnons-nous les moyens d'organiser
d'imposer ce référendum Marion marchel
qui invite ti pour le LR Jordan Bardella
pour le rassemblement national Nicolas
duponteignan également à à la rejoindre
sur ce RIP vous me voyez venir parce qu'
Perino c'est le c'est le le l'Union des
droites don dont rêve Erric Zemour ce
thème de l'immigration c'est peut-être
le thème le plus favorable à une union
des droites ça suffit pas à faire l'ion
des
droites ils ont ils s'en sont aperçus
dans le passé ils vont s'en apercevoir
dans l'avenir ça ne suffit pas faire
d'Illes a déjà
répondu suffit pas à faire l'union des
droites d'autre part les choses sont
plus compliquées que Madame maréchal
lecroix il faut une réforme de la
Constitution donc il suffit pas de dire
il y a qu'à faudrait voyez et d'autre
part on est dans la précampagne
européenne Marion maréchal a envie
d'exister tous les sondage montre qu'il
a apparemment il y a une dynamique très
forte en faveur de la liste du
rassemblement national emmené par Jordan
Bardella et que la liste de Marion
maréchal Le Pen pour l'instant joue les
accessoires elle n'est pas au premier
rang des forces politiques et donc pour
elle il faut absolument exister et
donner l'impression que ça se passe
autour d'elle et non pas autour de
Jordan Bardella oui dernière question
référendaire évidemment char parce qu'il
y a
aussi cette lettre envoyée par Emmanuel
Macron au différents chefs de de parti
pour rééditer on va dire les rencontres
de Saint-Denis rendez-vous lancé pour le
17 novembre il y a déjà le Parti
socialiste et LFI qui ont répondu qu'il
ne s'y rendrait pas la le le CLIN d'œil
à la droite était peut-être trop voyante
avec trop voyant avec l'idée d'un de la
possibilité d'élargir le champ du
référendum de l'article 11 à des
questions de société et notamment les
questions migratoires mais c'est un peu
le problème du en même temps
c'est-à-dire que à partir du moment où
on essaie de séduire à droite et de
séduire à gauche comme il l'a d'ailleurs
essayé avec cette réforme
constitutionnelle ambitionné au 4
octobre c'estàdire un peu d'IVG pour les
ailes plus à gauche et un peu
territorial pour le Sénat un peu plus de
peuple pour séduire le peuple et en fait
je pense que avec tous ces appels c'est
très difficile de faire une réforme
cohérente et en plus d'arriver à ne
cliver personne aujourd'hui la question
d'un référendum sur l'immigration euh
posera à mon avis beaucoup de questions
au cours du débat parlementaire qui ne
manquera pas d'exister si on réforme la
Constitution comme il se doit et je
crois en effet que les groupes de gauche
ont vu le le fil très très grossier qui
était joué en
par le chef de l'État même si à gauche
on a essayé de jouer sur l'international
en en précisant justement qu'il y avait
des choses à discuter sur le conflit
israëlo-palestinien donc l'idée c'est
toujours de se dire que à partir du
moment où Emmanuel Macron essaie de
jouer le consensus il est sûr d'chouer
mais il peut aussi avoir ce coup
politique de faire retomber la
responsabilité sur les oppositions donc
peut-être qu'on est aussi dans dans ce
jeu-là merci un tout dernier mot allez-y
ou pour revenir sur cette question du
référendum je pense qu'on sait que c'est
des questions émidment complexes les
questions migr soir que un référendum
appelle plutôt une question simple et
par ailleurs ces questions se jouent
quand même principalement à l'échelle
européenne et il y a un texte en ce
moment qui est en préparation le pacte
asile et immigration et c'est quand même
vers cela aussi qu'on doit tourner le
regard même si ça nous occupe beaucoup
au niveau français et dans notre dans
notre hémicycle en ce moment merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce à ce débat bientôt sur Public Sénat